this is really just getting sad i have
video for you today of an extremely
disheveled sounding my pillow mike
lindell
claiming that every utah vote is fake in
his latest febrile tirade
about machines and elections and all
these different things we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines okay so here is pillow
saying nobody's really voting in utah it
is all completely fabricated
you know i believe you have the ccp
the globalist the uni party i believe
it's all one just happy family and and
uh and we showed it on on all the 50
states you get to utah where there's no
um
one for a day election it's all mailed
in as pure crime nobody votes in utah
nobody brandon it's all just made up
so utah is a state of about 3 million
people 3.1 million people roughly live
in utah and some of them are adults and
some of them are registered to vote and
some of them actually do vote
and the idea that just it's all made up
because it's mail-in is completely and
totally absurd now i'm actually willing
to go further it's not just that no one
votes in utah
i don't even know that utah is real
i haven't been there i've never met
anyone from utah i know mitt romney
exists but do we really know that when
he left massachusetts after being
governor he really went to this place
called utah we really don't now of
course i'm kidding but in all
seriousness
we have a country
where
i don't know that i would say half
but a whole bunch of people
watch
people like pillow
for entertainment purposes only right we
know he's nuts or very confused or some
combination of the two or not with it
and we see it as a complete and total
joke and we watch to ask and to see
answered
how far
are others willing to go
in believing that anything this guy says
is based in reality right so we exist
these people are so susceptible to being
propagandized then it's just funny to
see
the other half of the country and again
it's not really half a lot of people
just don't pay attention they'd have no
clue who pillow is but you've got
another portion
that is so susceptible to being tricked
and scammed and propagandized by people
like mike pillow
um alex jones
all of these different people thank your
lucky stars every day you're not dave
pacman i know i know
and it's really an incredible contrast
and it doesn't have to be that way
they're they're i i promise you we get
emails from all over the world and you
know i've been to so many different
places and engaged with the political uh
uh
with political activists and systems in
a lot of countries people disagree about
policy
but you don't have a large portion of
the population to susceptible to clowns
like this guy you just don't nobody
falls for it yeah
tiny tiny portions of the population
fall for it and the vast majority of the
political discourse is sane here's one
other clip from the pillow stuff
um
mike lindell
is reacting to it sort of seems like
he's lost steve bannon it seems like
steve bannon is not falling for all of
the machine stuff
but pillow says no no no he secretly
still believes all of it everybody knows
uh steve bannon and he always says on
his show i'm not a machine guy now you
know what i mean he said that to me
yesterday he said that to me yesterday
in the booth i'm not really a machine
guy right so then we get yeah he says
that i think so you know
deep down of course he's of course he
believes the machine's got to go of
course he does he's afraid of dominion
or smart man right
at the end of the night everybody
i said so steve are you a machine guy
now he goes i'm a machine guy yeah
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines yeah my espresso
machine is currently uh being deposed
it's crazy
um this reminds me a little bit of the
jordan peterson clip we looked at this
clip in detail because it's so
fascinating where jordan peterson said
there aren't really atheists
there are people who claim to be
atheists but deep down they really
aren't
and of course that type of statement is
completely unfalsifiable
if even what people claim to be isn't
really what they are then you can't
really actually talk about things like
atheism there's no atheist because even
the group that describes themselves that
way they're actually religious deep down
really which religion i don't know
christianity i sort of guess
this stuff is absolutely hilarious and
they're he has a following and that's
maybe the scariest thing about the
united states